hey I was Sara peachy Ron bliss
peachy I didn't miss open use like every
time I think is your name I'm like girl
it's a very hard name to remember in on
the spare key so he and the comical
channels of all physical textile is New
York but she's in LA right now good the
weather I'm not used to the weather
being so perfect is so awesome so we did
a video on her channel talking about the
Apple watch the wall holding the
scriptures and annotation wherever
somewhere is going to be behind it no
big idea now we are going to be talking
today about iPhone 8 wish list and
here's the thing because people have
been talking about iphone 7 s iphone 8
potentially coming out of same time
maybe it's not even called and I believe
may be called my phone s we don't know
gosh there's so many variables to think
about by going on it and see if it's the
iPhone X I feel like my number one
wishlist thing will come true I think
it's the same okay anyway looks okay so
right it also our wish list
however tiny we're just gonna basically
just talk and see what happens you know
we're talking potentially next iPhone
potentially ad iPhone afterthought but
my next icon which looks number one
which we've been dancing highway three
two one
I'm a guy to match mine watch she has to
happen do it why she ran so pretty I
don't know how practical is I equally be
so expensive
this is thirteen hundred thousand volts
on mine yes probably 25 three thousand
like expenses I haven't converted to the
Dom boy yet I'm so rocking get this this
is gonna surprise you I edit everything
on a 2012 maximum it it has a 16 gigs of
RAM and I said and everything but I
can't live with him sweetheart slaughter
part about her with New York I forgot
McDonald I forgot and this meet the card
reader I forgot a charger and then I
went the Apple store and they were sold
hours my
her into a MacBook Pro wishlist wasn't
not so bad really bad he thought my
sense of USB be because I do and then
have work endoscope role little flexible
to Mike Romanow guys can see I feel like
my entire life is slowly now on this PC
so that is a huge huge wishlist hands
down people it is number two on your
list or event you know number two is a
headphone jack oh I know they wanted to
move to dis life and I look - yeah I
love the airport life however I still
use headphones and I think do you think
that something is going to disappear in
five years probably I mean itís courage
taken
I think at this point Taylor I'm going
to go back I've already realized it's
not going to happen yeah at all but then
it's going to be super confusing Canales
can be us PC and that everybody the Bob
lightning headphones to go with it boned
it's not it's just a struggle
well next on my list was an Olaf screen
the devil help with battery right let's
go that means also again it's not almond
yes like a wish list yes kids I feel
like every other Android cold point has
it and of course they're looking down
all thats Apple people saying hello
we've had just for years
I don't know again just might go back to
the ceramic being more durable but I
would like to have an iPhone 3 eyes like
a white wrap on it and so I think it you
know when you drop it incessant I think
it provides a little bit higher for
scratches and dropping just something
that just enough for the phone cigarette
Kingston I just hate pieces you can you
to know I'm so irresponsible that I have
a super small cute location that is like
basically just like their little kind of
standing up shadow my phone three times
be in four days so I was like I think I
can't do that and then now I'd like to
protect enough green on it because I am
reckless but it looks clean
I do like the black yes you know all
black it was good
hello I don't another one but you say
you say you're okay my wireless charge
that's that one on - Sam no embrasure it
make sense man the reverse it was going
to happen in this zone I mean if it
doesn't happen the next phone totally
complete like you've got out we need to
get on it you have to it I also have no
fee charge nurses have wireless charging
built into the case hmm already have
this is easy just ignore it
have you ever used the wireless charging
like at Starbucks or you like put in the
ring and you like set it now I've seen
it it's cool it's cool
it's to meet my got something I can do
is I mean this is always on my list no
matter how good the camera is I want a
better camera you which one do you have
so yeah I am just playing but I
want to free it has been nice to have to
like do it feature and stuff and I've
taken some pictures and good lighting in
New York that just blow my mind socially
when it comes to Lily I think there's
always room and video for some reasons
the microwave Oh dick that's what I want
I want this camera to have the same
quality as I don't know if I'm honest I
feel like a pretty easy yeah yeah I
think I can do that next I list so I
have been a really big fan of the pixel
camera like Google Talk it's a great
night it feels good and it'll have like
a little touch like I figure put
something in the back so before this
Apple is you can among emo who and it
does not have a button I'm what full
screen iPhone I was upset when they did
it the home button like where you
couldn't present
happen aired right took me a while to
get used tonight
I don't know I think we're so used to
him look so natural after using the
Bissell phones every time I would
shatter this like the pixel phone became
like my main most related couple of days
so you can even not about so be
depressing on the back it's a weird
thing you just like pick it up and it
over right there I don't think they'll
do the next one or maybe a couple them
yeah yeah maybe they will courage
courage I also see some rumors of them
doing facial recognition so I would work
as fast I don't know it's not necessary
I'll rather have that a bad
like batteries that's like my list in my
wishlist
let us know in the comments below what
you guys would like to see what hoping
for will be not one and use the one has
no jacket oh I only know I know ever
again
I know I'm excited about the future love
headphones but I need like with editing
and bluetooth I feel like that
technology still needs to catch up with
like allied and stuff well thank you for
having me and most insane honored she's
great she's a legend you probably know
this guy's to the left so it's amazing
for me to just be sitting here well
thank you so much and things that I mean
your videos you another ever last video
we talked about the Apple watch
but is it worth it yeah watch the video
[Applause]
[Music]